it's when you walk in on your parents
having sex and you are so petrified that
your whole face goes white you have
ghost cheeks that's happened to you
before yeah yeah literally
hey guys Christian's more here at the
Grammys red carpet and we're gonna play
a game to see if celebrities know the
definition to urban dictionary words are
you familiar with urban dictionary well
I live in the urban dictionary Oh how's
Chicago I know what they used to be
saying all right first word ghost sheeps
those cheeks dead cheeks like there's
like okay she has it until you look for
it he has a fake out it's like that but
really there is that when you slap a
girl's booty so hard and it disappears I
don't know Oh have you done that no I'm
just guessing it's when you use the
toilet seat and it's a little warm from
the last person I hate it no people like
that apparently all right next one
ding corrupt you're not as well-endowed
as you thought you are whoa that's what
you spend all your money by we you take
rub I'm out of weed yeah hey there we go
I'm cool okay I should have got that oh
no what is it who created these things
bro did we know the feeling now um no
let's move on yes all right okay clam
jam see another sexual one to me it
sounds like when someone has a witchy
kind of like a camel toe a clam jam is
like a intimate party so it's like
closed off but it's jamming oh that's
when you're all up in those clams like
literal clam no like clam is in vagina
oh it's a female equivalent to
cock-block talkbox
okay have you ever been claimed Jampa
full absolutely you're trying to talk to
him and she's like hi my name is Kjell
saying clam jam booth nan okay last one
insta lurking we all know that is me I
guess then you spend too much time on
Instagram going deep and not saying
nothing being all clandestine ish real
CIA that sounds like FBI work I've done
that before but you know Instagram
wasn't around back then so what was it
it was like Mar through his text on sky
til two waiters Oh
have you ever insular Kenny one before
maybe Megan make it maybe Selena
maybe Selena I have no shame I will go
through and like from the beginning and
it's not an accident if you get a like
from me you know what's up I want you to
go seek me I now on daughter you taught
me something I mean right here right now
reaching people